bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans le journal de tv 78 voici les
titres de ce mercredi 24 février
michel edouard leclerc était en
déplacement au sein de son centre situé
à rambouillet à l'invitation de la
députée de la circonscription
ils ont échangé sur le projet de loi
climat et résilience qui touchera la
grande distribution également chaque
jour des milliers de masques sont jetés
la question du recyclage se pose et
l'entreprise recorec a décidé d'y
répondre
une expérimentation vient de se mettre
en place pour trois mois avec la
municipalité de plaisir enfin comment
faire des rencontres amoureuses en temps
de pandémie mondiale
c'est la question que nous nous sommes
posée avec notre invité que nous
poserons avec michel toro conseillère en
agence matrimoniale à versailles
nous écouterons aussi les témoignages de
ceux qui cherchent l'amour avec le co
vie de 19 juste avant cela l'ancien
président de la république françois
hollande s'est déplacé à carrières sous
poissy ce matin le maire eddie aït l'a
accueillie pour rencontrer des jeunes de
la commune dans un tweet le premier
édile a indiqué qu'il souhaite mettre en
lumière l'engagement des jeunes et qu'il
sera à leurs côtés pour favoriser leur
autonomie
selon l'élu à carrières sous poissy
quatre habitants sur 10 ont moins de 30
ans
comme je vous le disais en titre le pdg
et de leclerc michel edouard leclerc a
répondu présent à l'invitation de la
députée de la 10e circonscription des
yvelines
aurore bergé ils ont visité le centre
leclerc de rambouillet pour parler du
projet de loi contre le dérèglement
climatique climat et résilience projet
de loi issu de la convention citoyenne
pour le climat dont la parlementaire a
été nommé rapporteur sur le volet
consommation
l'enjeu est grand pour les grandes
surfaces car cette loi aura un impact
sur l'avenir du commerce et de la
consommation
reportage avec agathe périlhou est monté
par rémi lefebvre la députée aurore
bergé et le grand patron michel edouard
leclerc ont visité le centre leclerc de
rambouillet lundi dernier une visite
dans le cadre du projet de loi climat et
résilience dont la député et rapporteur
pour le volet consommation
l'enjeu c'est comment on arrive à faire
entrer l'écologie dans le quotidien des
français
et comment on fait en sorte pour
concilier les objectifs écologiques avec
aussi des enjeux pragmatique sanitaires
économiques industrie donc être ici tout
simplement dans un magasin leclerc c'est
savoir si les objectifs qu'on se fixe
ils sont réalistes un rayon vrac des
publicités supprimer ou encore du miel
et de la viande locale
le centre leclerc de rambouillet fait
office de bon élève
c'était tout l'enjeu de cette visite
notamment pour michel edouard leclerc
prouver que la grande distribution
contribue à l'effort environnemental à
nos professionnels si on veut pas se
faire imposer une loi trop contraignante
et bien d'être force de proposition et
d'aller dans le même sens je pense qu'on
peut pas se contenter de critiquer
d'abord départ de cette loi il ya une
convention citoyenne donc il ya des
citoyens qui ont exprimé leur désir
donc on a beaucoup de propositions à
faire pour développer le bio pour
développer le local pour développer la
qualité sur les produits l'affichage
à l'issue de cette visite une table
ronde était également organisée entre la
parlement
faire le patron de leclerc et les autres
acteurs de la consommation comme lidl et
système u en moyen pour les grandes
surfaces de faire entendre leur voix
nous partons maintenant du côté de
plaisir comment éviter que les masques
jonchent le sol c'est devenu un enjeu
majeur notamment le recyclage est bien
un plaisir les masques des agents de la
commune sont désormais recyclés grâce à
un partenariat avec la société plaisir
oise grecque n'aurait qu une
expérimentation de trois mois a été mise
en place
des corbeilles dédié où ont été
installés dans les points stratégiques
et sont ensuite amenés par les agents
directement à l'entreprise reportage
d'astrid bergère et nicolas d'ennuis à
plaisir les masques des agents de la
ville sont maintenant recycler c'est
grâce à recques n'aurait qu'une société
basée dans la commune et qui produit des
matériaux éco responsable à partir de
déchets qui échappe aux filières de
recyclage après les avoir laissé deux
semaines à température ambiante pour des
contaminations
ils sont broyés pour obtenir des
paillettes des paillettes comme ça que
vous voyez où ailleurs donc nous masquer
les élastiques cvmq conduire ces masques
ne viennent donc pas de loin les agents
de la ville les ont déposés dans des
corbeilles dédié ils sont ensuite
collecté une fois par semaine et a mené
avec norrec pendant trois mois une
expérimentation est mise en place entre
l'entreprise et la commune un circuit
court qui permet d'allier écologie et
économie locale
oui on en rétribuant on est on est à
hauteur d'une somme qui a été entendue
avec eux pour pouvoir justement à voir
ce conventionnement pour eux c'est une
aide une aide au développement de
rentrer de leur entreprise et pour nous
c'est un vrai conventionnement je tairai
utile pratique on aimerait que ça se
développe davantage même dans les écoles
si possible on va bien voir avec rec
norrec comment ils sont capables de
récupérer tous ces matériaux le procédé
permet à l'entreprise de recycler le
masque en entier élastique et pince nez
en métal compris on l'a testé l'été
dernier on a vu que ça fonctionnait et
on s'est dit que pour que ce soit
sérieux il fallait que la matière finale
et de la valeur et donc soit de qualité
et donc on a déclenché les masses qui
une opération expérimentale pour finir
de mettre au point ce
ce procédé les plats créés que nos
règles fabriqués en partie avec les
masques peuvent devenir par exemple des
composteurs ou des nichoirs pour oiseaux
depuis le premier confinement en mars
2020 le kovy 19 a eu des impacts dans de
nombreux domaines c'est notamment le cas
pour les relations amoureuses pour en
parler avec nous ce soir justin brasier
journalistes de la rédaction
bonsoir mon sens alors c'est plus
compliqué de faire des rencontres avec
la crise sanitaire j'imagine il ya en
tout cas moins de possibilités de se
rencontrer de façon naturelle pour
plusieurs raisons déjà la réduction du
nombre de contacts pour éviter la
propagation et par peur aussi d'être
contaminés il est aussi compliqué de se
voir le soir avec le couvre-feu
à moins de revenir tôt ou d'habiter
ensemble mais bon ce n'est pas forcément
le cas en début de relation et puis
comment se découvrir dans la vraie vie
quand les établissements culturels ou
encore les restaurants et bars et
activités ne sont plus accessibles les
endroits où on pouvait faire des
rencontres comme les facs lycée tout ça
va comme ça on dit essentielle pour la
plupart c'est compliqué mais moins
tentés à parler aux gens on est vraiment
chacun dans notre bulle et sera peu
frustrant quand on a du mal à croiser
des personnes
on a du mal à aller vers les personnes
parce que déjà il ya la distance fin la
distanciation en fait donc du coup on a
de la retenue
faute de pouvoir se rencontrer dans un
bar où aller au resto en rencontrer des
gens un peu dans des milieux où il ya du
monde et de l'ambiance et recours à des
sites internet
je trouve pas ça vraiment original est
ce que j'aimerais moi c'est une
rencontre en bray peut-être que parler
sur internet ça fait voir en vrai et que
du coup ça peut aider des sites de
rencontres alors justin est ce que les
sites de rencontres ont eux aussi été
impactés alors on pourrait se dire que
c'est un peu la seule manière de se
rencontrer aujourd'hui alors match et
c'est bien mais quand vient l'heure de
la rencontre est bien le même fin les
mêmes problèmes se posent ça s'est
ressenti au niveau des chiffres dont
qu'on a pierre tabuteau qui est yves
binois plus précisément deux maisons
laffitte et il a créé son site de
statistiques qui s'appelle stats
rencontres.fr dans lequel il comparaît
comparez analyse les données de sites de
rencontres en france et donc selon une
étude publiée en janvier 2021 les sites
de rencontres généralistes auraient
connu une large baisse au 1er
confinement avec moins 60 % quand même
de fréquentation par rapport à l'année
il a vu ensuite un rebond à l'été 2020
ou là par contre la tendance est
inversée puisque la fréquentation a
connu une croissance de 20% quand même
par rapport à 2019 et ensuite face à la
deuxième vague est donc le deuxième
confinement d'africains la fréquentation
des sites de rencontres à elle de
nouveau baisser cette fois ci plus
légèrement avec moins 40% par rapport à
2010 9 mai donc moins 20% par rapport au
rebond de l'été 2021 eh bien merci
justin pour toutes ces précisions
chiffrées qui plus est et pour continuer
à parler des rencontres en temps de
pandémie mondiale
nous accueillons notre invité ce soir
michel taureau bonsoir vous êtes
conseillère au sein de l' agence
matrimoniale unis centre elle est située
à versailles alors on s'est beaucoup de
français se sentent seuls beaucoup
d'études sorte à ce sujet de sondages on
a parlé avec justin à l'instant entre
les confinements successifs les
couvre-feux les lieux de loisirs fermé
c'est difficile de faire des rencontres
pourtant les agences matrimoniales
vivent un véritable boom posco vide
en tout cas pose confinement les gens
cherchent à se rencontrer
mais dans quelle mesure est ce que c'est
le même public aussi qu'avant la crise
sanitaire
bonsoir oui c'était le même public mais
on sent bien qu'on récupère une partie
des personnes jeunes qu'on avait un
petit peu perdu il est qu'ils allaient
plutôt vers les sites
là c'est une période un peu anxiogène
les personnes ont besoin d'être rassurés
donc reviennent vers les agences de
rencontre sérieuse qu'on appelait avant
les agences matrimoniales
ça fait et voilà qu'une quarantaine
d'années que nous existions et on avait
un petit peu perdu ces jeunes ses cadres
supérieurs et ils reviennent énormément
parce qu'ils ont besoin d'un fuite d'une
conseillère qui puisse les rassurer
alors comment vous est adapté du coup en
tant qu agence matrimoniale c'est à dire
comment rassurer les personnes qui
veulent se rencontrer mais qui ont peur
avec le risque sanitaire justement alors
moi voilà moi
méthodes un peu particulières mois déjà
je me déplace alors évidemment pas comme
ce soir où là je suis dans mon bureau
mais je me déplace au début je suis
masqué il ya une distanciation et je
leur explique bien que les personnes
qu'elles vont rencontrer ou qu'ils vont
rencontrer j'ai je suis allé chez eux
donc je vais vérifier qu'elle était bien
seul je leur demande des papiers un
papiers de divorce une feuille de pelle
une carte d'identité parce que sully sur
les sites
les personnes peuvent raconter un petit
peu n'importe quoi on ne sait pas trop
qu'il ya derrière la ville sauf qu'avec
moi je vais vérifier tout ce qu'il me
dise ensuite on a un petit peu abordé
les centres d'intérêts et tout qui ont
toujours été voilà la marque de fabrique
d'une agence matrimoniale mais je pense
qu'ils ont besoin dans cette période
obscure gel de sécurité donc des
rencontres vérifier on l'a bien compris
alors là on l'a compris quand vous
rentrerez vous rencontrez part de vos
clients c'est sécurisé mais comment on
fait pour organiser un rendez-vous un
bate comme disent certains
entre deux clients alors même que les
lieux de rencontre on va dire habituel
le restaurant le cinéma et puis plein
d'autres sont fermés alors c'est vrai
que c'est un problème parce qu'avant et
que ceux rencontrés dans un restaurant
dans un petit salon tu es là on leur
conseille de ne pas se rencontrer chez
eux quand même toujours par sécurité
même si nous savons où ils habitent
mon fonds préfèrent qu'ils évitent de se
rencontrer chez eux donc on se rend
compte à l'extérieur lanmodez paris que
ce téléphone ils dialoguent et ensuite
se rend compte à l'extérieur même quand
il faisait très froid ils sont motivés
et maintenant je suis fait beau ils vont
dans les papes et ils se rencontrent à
l'extérieur il nous faut un compte rendu
après mais généralement une rencontre
très bien et quelle est votre vision
pour l'avenir en tant qu agence
matrimoniale
pensez vous que ce rebond d'inscription
que vous avez pu avoir et que vous avez
en ce moment va se poursuivre après
cette crise sanitaire et qui je l'espère
cette crise sanitaire sera bientôt
terminé je l'espère rires oui je pense
parce que sincèrement santé avant la
crise sanitaire
qu'il y avait un recul ed ce type de
rencontre je ne sais pas pourquoi ou les
algorithmes ont changé je ne sais pas on
sent vraiment que depuis 4 5 ans les
personnes reviennent vers les agences
parce que bon on se rencontre et
pourtant sur ces sites ci a chois cadix
ou 11 millions de célibataires en france
ça laisse à leur compte mais avant mais
maintenant on a l'impression qu'il y a
c'est un peu comme un catalogue il n'y a
pas vraiment de sérieux on sait pas
qu'il ya derrière les gens ne se
rencontrent pas les femmes sont pas très
motivés
enfin on sent qu'ils ont vraiment besoin
de savoir que je rencontre des personnes
qui ont un projet de vie qui ont envie
de construire quelque chose et ça il ya
parfois par une agence qui sont rassurés
sur ce point là et justement pour vous
c'est dû à quoi ce désamour un petit peu
des agences matrimoniales comme on
l'entend vraiment anciennes comme vous
le disiez qui existe depuis quand même
de nombreuses années je crois qu'on a eu
une image un peu ringard de par rapport
à ces sites c'est voilà moi il ya
beaucoup d'adhérents qui me disent
n'attendez on sait même pas que vous
existiez encore alors c'est vrai qu'on a
pu ces journaux en papier gratuit qu'on
distribué dans les boîtes aux lettres
on savait qu'on existe et où aller
personne même qui est en couple me
disait ah je ris gay quand j'étais en
haute joaillerie vos petites annonces et
où je ne pensais jamais pouvoir passer
par où on a plus ce support papier
donc il faut quand même qu'ils aillent
sur les sites qu'ils aillent se
rencontre sérieuse sur agence
matrimoniale
ils sont tout à fait surpris de savoir
qu'on existe encore alors que moi voilà
je travaille depuis plus de vingt ans
qu'on a toujours existé que j'ai
plusieurs agences on a toujours été là
mais ils reviennent et les ans même
alors du coup est-ce que vous avez un
public plutôt jeune plutôt vieux ce que
je sais que la concurrence comme vous
l'avez rappelé est rude avec les sites
de rencontres sur internet
beaucoup de jeunes justement les
utilisent comment on attire les jeunes
comment la tire la jeunesse vers les
agences matrimoniales
alors moi je suis étonné parce que quand
j'avais quand même ma plus jeune
adhérent qui a 23 ans et je suis la
première à elle a à dire quand ces
jeunes viennent chez nous sam attendait
vous avez comme des moyens de recours
c'est vrai plus difficile mais il ya
comme un réseau d'amis et tout
et je pense qu'ils vont vraiment fait
aussi besoin d'être assurés comme le
disais tout à l'heure à nos jeunes
il ya tellement de possibilités de
rencontres sur les campus tout le monde
est un petit peu en visio et c'est vrai
que c'est difficile et on récupère
beaucoup de jeunes moi je suis étonné
que ces jeunes reviennent énormément on
avait perdu ses jeunes le 22 23 à 30 ans
et en est pourtant les premières à leurs
vivres tomber rencontrez-vous et c'est
pas si évident c'est grand besoin aussi
d'être assuré eh bien merci michel
taureau en tout cas d'avoir été avec
nous et pour toutes ces précisions
direction saint germain en laye
maintenant le quartier clos saint louis
va connaître une transformation jusqu'en
2026 un projet d'écoquartier avec
plusieurs infrastructures sociales des
logements ou encore des sites de loisirs
tout cela en préservant le patrimoine
historique
les précisions de nicolas landry sur les
images de michael et demi d'euros il va
avoir un nouveau visage en 2026 le
quartier de l'hôpital va devenir un éco
quartier à saint germain en laye 5000 m²
de commerces 450 logements une crèche
une résidence seniors ou encore une
maison médicale un projet de
réaménagement qui prévoit quelques
destructions
ce n'est pas une opération de
construction c'est plutôt un projet
autour du bien-être du cadre de vie des
habitants de saint germain et puis c'est
aussi conserver le patrimoine
hospitalier du 19e le rénover ça a été
vraiment pensé comme un nouveau quartier
mais ouvert sur le reste du centre
ancien le lien social sera privilégiée
avec un espace de rencontres entre
habitants avec la conciergerie autres
secteurs privilégiés le loisir avec un
cinéma ugc un hôtel de 80 chambres et un
restaurant panoramique installé en haut
d'un des deux châteaux d'eau
c'est tout à fait exceptionnel et je
pense que ça permet aussi d'attirer pas
mal de personnes extérieures à saint
germain c'est aussi de trouver le moyen
pour que un des deux dômes
des châteaux d'eau puissent est
accessible de manière totalement
gratuite au public qu'ils puissent
profiter du panorama le patrimoine
historique sera préservée notamment avec
cette église ce nouvel écoquartier sera
piéton et cyclable
aujourd'hui le projet rentre dans une
nouvelle phase dans quelques semaines le
permis d'aménager et les permis de
construire vont être instruit par là la
ville
il va y avoir une maison de projets qui
devraient ouvrir dans les semaines qui
viennent
en centre ville les premières
démolitions vont débuter à l'été 2000 21
l'ensemble du projet sera réalisé par
tranches jusqu'en 2026 date prévue pour
la livraison pour refermer ce journal
une note musicale à présent le nouveau
morceau du rappeur kirtas sera
disponible est disponible même sur soir
sur sa chaîne youtube et ses réseaux
sociaux dédiés à la ville de trappes le
saint quentinois a tourné le clip le
week-end dernier dans la commune nous
vous en parlions lundi vous pouvez voir
et revoir notre reportage sur tv5 18
points comme on se quitte avec cet
extrait merci d'avoir suivi ce journal
une très bonne soirée à toutes et à tous
quittons club plutôt que vous récup
touche à trappes tu touche-à-tout saint
quentin
nous sommes au seuil juif athée et
chrétiens à quoi bon parler en union
histoire on répond aux critiques avec
quelques notes et sport
il ya un moment donné il faut faire on
est pris en otage par certaines
personnes une minorité des prix vous
fait la promo de ça mais vous savez très
bien qu'un qu'un canard qui tombe fait
plus de bruit qu'une fois qu'ils
poussent et ces gens là ils sont
spectaculaires
je répète soyons dans une recherche qui
mène à nantes
[Musique]